[Music]
video game fans have plenty of questions
about the movie adaptation of uncharted
for one did tom holland really pull off
the role of nathan drake even after
seeing the film some questions will
linger keep watching for the biggest
after being caught breaking and entering
and threatened with prison nate's
brother sam escapes from the orphanage
where the brothers live sam promises
he'll come back but he never does
leaving nate to wonder where sam went
nate's mentor victor sully sullivan
admits that sam used to be his treasure
hunting partner yet he avoids talking
about sam's fate for most of the film i
think you're here because you're your
brother well you know my brother said
eventually it becomes clear that sully
and his sometimes ally chloe believes
sam is dead the mercenary braddock even
indicates she's the one who killed him
at the end of the film though there's a
brief scene set in a dingy prison that
indicates sam is still kicking we see a
man writing a postcard the form of
communication he used to reach out to
nate but where is he and how did he
survive as sully chloe and braddock all
thought they saw him die there are
several tantalizing ways that nate and
sully could learn about sam's situation
they could find out from a third party
and rescue him nate could find out sully
secretly knows the truth about sam
leading to a rift or sam could escape
and seek out the pair in some unexpected
way there's plenty of fodder for a
sequel
uncharted makes it seem as though
santiago mankata is the film's main
villain but when braddock the mercenary
he hired kills him midway through the
film she becomes the true antagonist
mankato was willing to do whatever it
took to find and claim magellan's
treasure but he didn't like to get his
hands dirty braddock on the other hand
is more than happy to get her hands
dirty and has a band of goons who seem
to share her cutthroat impulses that
doesn't mean she's a great villain her
motivations mostly seem to revolve
around the desire for a massive payday
still she keeps the film's fight scenes
interesting including the final fight on
one of magellan's ships when she loses
the fight and falls into the ocean that
ship ends up crashing into the water on
top of her given the circumstances it
seems like braddock must have died on
contact but there are plenty of movies
that have made it seem like the villain
is dead only to resurrect them in the
sequel if say braddock was a strong
swimmer she could have gotten away
before the ship hit the sea and we
wouldn't have seen it
the movie's mid-credits sequence sets up
nate and sully's next adventure nate
meets a man with an eye patch to make a
trade to acquire a map that will lead to
nazi treasure although it's never clear
what specifically he's hoping to find in
world war ii the nazis confiscated and
looted all kinds of valuable art and
artifacts so it wouldn't be all that
surprising if nate and sully decided to
go after one of those treasures besides
nazis come up a couple of times during
the uncharted game so it's possible
their mention in the mid credits scene
is an indication that although this
uncharted film told an original story
the plot of the sequel will take its
cues from the plot of one of the games
either way going up against nazis is a
popular trope in action adventure films
everyone from indiana jones to captain
america have done it so perhaps it's no
surprise that nathan drake and sully
would do so as well
the man that nate meets in the
mid-credits scene references his boss
during their exchange we don't know much
about this boss but one of the things he
requests in exchange for the nazi map is
the ring nate wears on a strap around
his neck the ring has sentimental value
for nate it was originally sam's and sam
gave it to nate when he left yet as nate
points out it has no real world value
the man with the eyepatch's boss isn't
seeking financial gain though his boss
wants it because it has value to nate it
seems as though this unseen boss could
be an interesting antagonist of course
it's unclear whether he will be the main
villain in the next movie as nate and
sully could find themselves racing
against someone else to claim the
treasure yet the fact that this boss is
still unknown indicates he could be a
big player in the next film could this
be a villain from the uncharted games or
maybe it's sam himself after all if sam
escaped from prison and amassed his own
gang it could explain why the man with
the eye patch said his boss wanted
nate's ring
in the last moments in the mid-credits
scene sully shows up to help nate when
the meeting with the man with the eye
patch goes south after sully gets the
situation under control nate and sully
leap together they bicker about sully's
delayed arrival until they see something
that stops them in their tracks the
final second of the film shows them
looking dumbfounded but what do they see
it's entirely possible that they run
into a new character or characters that
we won't meet until the sequel or they
may have encountered a character we're
familiar with perhaps braddock is really
alive and has finally hunted them down
or perhaps this is the point where sam
reveals he's still among the living
there are a ton of possibilities but
without an idea of the potential story
for the sequel it's hard to narrow them
down what else aren't you telling me
sully summons chloe frazier when he and
nate first arrive in spain even though
chloe initially antagonizes them they
eventually team up to track down a map
to help them find magellan's gold nate
and sully quickly learned she wasn't
entirely trustworthy she was actually
working for mankata and she regularly
makes it clear that she doesn't trust
anyone even so she eventually helps them
reclaim the artifacts they need from
mankato's plane by the time nate figures
out the location of the treasure he
knows he can't trust chloe so he leaves
a set of fake coordinates just in case
she takes off before he wakes up
unfortunately for chloe she takes the
bait which means instead of finding the
gold with him she goes on a wild goose
chase
the movie gives no indication of what
that means for her relationship with
nate or sully leaving open the question
of what could happen if she ever meets
up with them again
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one